[Musique]
non
l auteur et photographe
et les photographes sont des lève tôt
car c'est à l'aube que la lumière est la
plus belle du haut de la table mountain
la montagne de la table
[Musique]
caressée par deux océans l'atlantique à
l'ouest et l'indien au sud
[Musique]
le cap est une ville coup de foudre
il
faudrait être aveugle pour ne pas voir
la beauté du cac ne peut regarder dans
toutes les directions
tombe toujours sur quelque chose
d'incroyablement beau il ya d'abord ce
cadre naturel ses plages mais cette
lumière et ses montagnes à des théories
à l'intérieur il y as elven magnifique
mannequin de peaches
aide travail à un ouvrage de
photographies sur sa ville
direction le quartier de beaux cap une
petite touche d'asie en afrique
ici on a du sens mallet et des ancêtres
esclaves
une main d'oeuvre que les colons
néerlandais ont fait venir des indes il
y a quatre cents ans
[Musique]
cette ville est vraiment fait pour les
photographes là on est à deux pas du
centre-ville et pourtant à boca
caste on a vraiment l'impression d'être
dans un petit village avec toutes ses
maisons colorées
j'ai juste à venir au bon moment pour
faire ressortir la lumière et tout ces
ombres
il y à mille couleurs au cap
et beaucoup de contrastes
les riches villas des quartiers blancs
les townships toujours habité par les
noirs
au centre tout se mélange
les époques les décors et même les
continents
[Musique]
aide va nous en faire la démonstration
action
regardez-moi au premier plan avec ce
bâtiment derrière il suffit qu'il soit
un peu floue et tout de suite vous avez
l'impression que je suis à new york
arrive dans une de ces longues avenues
bordées d'immeubles
[Musique]
allez avec un peu d'imagination et
quelques accessoires c'est pavé ce café
à l'angle c'est paris
à
deux rues de new york juste en face de
paris imaginons la scène deux personnes
en train de marcher de se parler nous
sommes dans une de ses rues si typique
c'est qu'on a fait le tour du monde dans
un seul pat ewing a accès parce qu'au
québec on trouvera tous les styles
architecture les néerlandais les anglais
chaque puissance coloniale a laissé son
empreinte sur la ville d'och ce ne sont
pas des répliques exactes mais ce qui
compte ce sont surtout des ambiances
assez pour que l'on n'y croit
le cap est une vraie ville caméléon elle
a juste besoin d'être un peu ma cliente
que dalle
dans ces photos ed cherche à révéler
tous ces univers qui vivent côte à côte
des maisons coloniales sur les hauteurs
de la ville
aux façades rétro des quartiers les plus
branchés
je suis toujours à l'affût des couleurs
des motifs des textures et c'est encore
mieux quand tout ça se combinent
ce que j'aime sa capture et la vie dans
la rue je me définis comme photographe
de rue le cas
ce sont ces décors qui attire les
photographes du monde entier
dans une atmosphère très british un
shooting vient de commencer
est ce que tu veux bien bouger ta main
sous l'oeil des mille-îles gambade c'est
la directrice de l'édition sud-africaine
du magazine elle
elle a quel âge
son équipe préparent une dizaine de lots
pour un numéro spécial tendance urbaine
de la rentrée
des cas le toit
il ya toujours un tas de publicité et le
shooting qui ont lieu dans les rues du
cap les gens ne font même plus attention
à l'instar regarder les voitures
continuent de rouler se passe dans
l'indifférence générale
des scènes de la vie quotidienne qui
pourrait avoir lieu n'importe où en
europe elles sont shootés ici à 9000
kilomètres du vieux continent
ce qu'on essaie de faire c'est de
trouver des endroits qui ne ressemble
pas au cap
par exemple nous ne voulons pas
nous cherchons à raconter une histoire
qui soit universelle
j'adore le contraste entre le bleu et le
rouge
les équipes viennent du monde entier
pour shooter ici une autre elle y trouve
toutes les ambiances qu'elle recherche
et des millions de possibilités de
tournage et surtout les saisons sont
inversées
de septembre octobre jusqu'à mars avril
il fait beau tout le temps
alors c'est tout l'hémisphère nord qui
débarque au cap et dans la région pour
ses shootings
bon allez on y va
[Musique]
si le cap est pris d'assaut par les
professionnels de l'image c'est aussi
pour sa région
[Musique]
on y trouve dans un rayon de 100 km une
variété exceptionnelle de paysages
ici on pourrait se croire sur une île
déserte en plein pacifique
là quelque part en bretagne
[Musique]
mais aussi en plein far west
ou dans le massif central
[Musique]
un catalogue grandeur nature
entre plaine d'apocalypse les
territoires vierges comme au premier
matin du monde
[Musique]
c'est dans ce dernier décor que head
s'aventure aujourd'hui il est en plein
repérage
le photographe à un second métier caster
de lieu pour le cinéma et la télévision
j'ai fait ce job pendant dix ans à
londres et l'essentiel de mon travail
s'était trouvé des pavillons des arrêts
de bus des rues bondées et quand je suis
revenu en afrique du sud la première
chose qu'on m'a demandé pour une pub
s'était trouvé une cascade
je n'y ai pas cru j'ai passé mon temps
dans des parcs des réserves naturelles à
faire de la randonnée et à chercher la
plus belle des cascades
aujourd'hui elle prépare le tournage
d'une des prochaines grosses séries
américaines
regardez cet endroit
c'est complètement préservé sa mise à
part ces quelques maisons et ses bateaux
dans le script le réalisateur a été très
explicite
il veut une plage qui pourrait
ressembler à la méditerranée
la scène est censée se dérouler en grèce
et entre le blanc du sable et le bleu de
l'eau on s'y croirait presque
mon principal critère c'est la houle la
mère doit être calme comme la
méditerranée j'ai donc choisi un endroit
en retrait qui ne donne pas directement
sur l'atlantique
l'eau pourrait aussi être turquoise
endroit qui correspondent au scénario
mais qui soit aussi facile d'accès pour
l'équipe de temps
ces photos seront envoyés aux états unis
si elles plaisent aide reviendra sur
place avec le réalisateur en personne
je pense que ça peut faire illusion on
pourrait se croire en méditerranée
[Musique]
es2 finirait bien sa carrière au cap là
où tout a commencé
là où jeunes photographes ils s'étaient
promis d'aller parcourir le monde loin
de la célèbre montagne de la table
en
j'ai mis beaucoup de temps pour en
arriver là faire le métier dont je
rêvais et dans cette région du cap en
plus quelle chance
ces crèmes c'est une ville
incroyablement belle s'élève
à les coucher de soleil sont comme une
institution ici on cherche toujours le
meilleur endroit pour en profiter
jusqu'au bout
magnifique quelle couleur et quel
plaisir mais je ne voudrais pas faire
trop de jeunes
jaloux non mais amoureux du cap sans
aucun doute